he asks uh what are the experiences from
the first five to ten years of your
career that were most memorable
and you feel impacted your path to where
you are today
well i think within the first
i think within the first 10 years of my
career
black people got to be on national
television more doing comedy because
within the first 10 years of my career
comic view and def jam were created
and that brought you out of the clubs
and on television which will get you
more
dates and more money in the clubs
because you've not been on television
make your celebrity
so i think it would have to be going
mainstream on television
um were there any early like
doubts or like hurdles you had to
overcome just from
like oh the ups and downs of being a
comedian
well of course because before i'm a
comedian i'm a mother
and i worked on i was i was in makeup
when i went into labor
i worked every day up until the day i
had my child
and i was in clubs and everything like
that i wasn't traveling as much
but i was locally like the it girl i was
doing like
four or five clubs a week in oakland
california
and then once i had my child
um you know
i still was working uh in in oakland in
the bay area
and sometimes i would have to take my
baby with me
in the car seat and hire on stage
sometime i would have to
burp her on stage with the baby on my
shoulder and the microphone
and this other hand my daughter's father
was a comedian
as well at that time he's retired now
comedians don't really retire
they die but he retired because he sort
of
he didn't he didn't move with the times
with his material and he started to fade
out
and so he just got a regular job and was
taking
help take care of the kids so sometimes
i would have to have her on my shoulder
and pass her out to him he would come to
the club pick her up you know
um it was very hard to fly away and
leave your child if they have the
whooping cough or something like that
especially being the mother you want to
make sure they got rubbed on with this
you want to make sure that covers are on
them
and it's been it's been very very
difficult very very stressful
i'm proud to say now uh that my
daughter's 24 years old very
independent and just gave me a whole
bunch of yesterday about not being
around when she was growing up
so they're going to grow up and throw it
back in your face
when they get older as much as you try
to do the right thing
you know so that's always hard for a
mother
uh wanting a mother or a wife in this
business
hey hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch
more videos to get even more comedy tips